welcome to pymol 101 with molecular
memory
I'm KP and in this lesson we'll learn to
use color in pymol by default Primal
applies a version of CPK coloring where
oxygen is red
nitrogen is blue
sulfur is yellow
and phosphorus is orange
sometimes it's useful to override this
especially to look at the overall
structure of a macromolecule we'll also
explore transparency in this lesson to
make our colors shine through let's do
this
phosphofructokinase pfk for short is a
protein that speeds up a chemical
reaction so it's an enzyme
it's the third enzyme in glycolysis a
10-step pathway that breaks down the
carbohydrate glucose pfk is cool because
it can interconvert between two shapes
or conformations depending on chemical
signals in the cell one confirmation
speeds up the reaction more efficiently
than the other allowing this enzyme to
act as a main control valve determining
whether we break down carbohydrates for
energy otherwise we can store them or
make bigger molecules in biosynthesis
load the biological assembly of 6 pfk in
pymol
file getpdb
6 pfk assembly one
display the sequence and let's scroll
through it we see breaks in the amino
acid sequences and this is because pfk
has four chains of amino acids it's a
multi-chain protein with quaternary
structure this particular structure is
the less active form of pfk
and each subunit is bound to PGA
we're not focusing on water molecules in
this lesson so let's hide them
H Waters
let's color the chains to see them
easily
in the names panel click the see button
for color
choose by chain and then the Top Choice
this star LMC means we're applying CPK
coloring to show the elements now in the
sequence select a PGA and zoom in on it
using the a button notice the CPK
coloring this orange atom here is
phosphorus Zoom back out using 6pfk to
view the whole protein and I don't want
this selection to get in the way of my
next steps so I'm going to go ahead and
use the a button to delete it let's add
a surface rendering name is panel S
button surface
to layer a surface rendering on top of
the default cartoon with CPK coloring
applied the surface is busy detracting
from the chain coloring surface may be a
rendering where CPK coloring is less
preferred
click C by chain and select the last
choice
this colors each chain a solid color
without cbk coloring
yeah now we're really highlighting the
four chains of pfk
now let's color by SS secondary
structure
this highlights Alpha helices Beta
sheets and areas of the protein without
a defined secondary structure called
loops
but this rendering isn't super useful
with the protein shown as surface since
the bumpy surface obscures the secondary
structure
hide the surface to reveal the cartoon
beneath now that's cool and very useful
what if we want to show both the
secondary structure and the protein
surface
we can make the surface
semi-transparent to achieve this
add the surface back using the show
button
now use the drop down setting menu find
Transparency surface and let's go with
60 percent
now let's make the Surface stand out a
little better by changing its color
C
by rep
surface
and let's choose one of the Grays the
secondary structure of the multi-color
cartoon we see beneath is determined by
hydrogen bonds between the amino acid
backbone atoms which are called main
chain in the pie mole menus
but we can also see the bumpiness of the
surface that's where amino acid side
chains are taking up space let's add
these side chains show side chains
sticks and we can now see how these fit
into the surface
the sticks are kind of thick and the
rendering is looking much too busy so
let's hide the sticks
now let's show lines instead and color
them with CPK coloring
now choose C by element each of these
choices and there are several sets of
them
Colors by a modified CPK coloring where
we choose the carbon color carbons don't
have to be gray or black as they are in
traditional CPK coloring choose either
cyan or white carbons from this first
set cyan is a light blue green color
that's relatively colorblind friendly
when choosing the carbon color it's
important to think about the atoms in
your structure when modeling proteins we
want to avoid colors that are similar to
the blue red and yellow of CPK nitrogen
oxygen and sulfur because we find these
in amino acids next we'll play with the
rendering of PGA but before we do that a
quick terminology break we mentioned
this is the less active conformation and
PGA helps Force the enzyme into this
shape because it's an inhibitor
Inhibitors slow or stop an enzyme from
performing a chemical reaction and
anything that binds to a protein can be
generally called a ligand or ligand so
the inhibitor is a ligand okay let's try
a new representation to get a sense of
where the ligands bind to the protein
using the sequence select all four pgas
you can click on each individually in
the sequence or click and drag over all
four at once the letters s-e-l-e come up
in the names panel next to that let's
click a rename and we'll call these
ligands
now show these as spheres
remember show as changes the rendering
completely by contrast plain old show
lets you layer representations on top of
each other like we have with the stick
and surface views of the protein cool
the location of the ligands is easy to
see now
let's make their carbon atoms contrast
the protein a bit more but still color
by element C by element and choose one
with green carbon atoms the cartoon is
another rendering that can have
transparency let's hide the lines and
surface go back to cartoon rendering and
apply transparency
this is a good time to use show as
6 pfk show as cartoon
notice this command cleared both the
lines and the surface but it also
cleared the sphere rendering of the
ligand no problem that's why we made a
selection for the object we're focusing
on
next to Liggins s spheres to get the
ligand Back Now setting drop down
transparency cartoon 50 and now we can
see both secondary structure and the
location of the ligand the type of
rendering you choose for a model really
depends on what you want to show the
viewer
it's a good idea to think about this
before starting the model but don't be
afraid to play around with the
renderings to find the best display
possible thanks for watching this
episode of Primal 101 next time we'll
refresh and build on techniques from
lesson two to show and label a binding
site on pfk
if you're enjoying this series like
subscribe and if there's anything
specific you'd like to learn let me know
in the comments